make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today in our beyond omega-level series
we are tackling a character that is
without a doubt one of the strongest
entities in the Marvel Universe also
known as a praxis so as we do in these
videos let's go into the origin of
Abraxas and then go over what his powers
and abilities are so Abraxas was created
by Jeph Loeb and Kevin McGuire and first
appeared in Fantastic Four annual in
2001 now in this issue we see the
Fantastic Four gathered around what
appears to be the head of Galactus that
is landed in the middle of Times Square
now Reed Richards quickly determines
however that this is not the Galactus
they know and concludes that it must be
some alternate universe version of him
that has basically been murdered now
when they look inside Galactus a severed
head read and been fine nova a former
Herald of Galactus in a comatose state
now keep in mind this is not Nova as in
a member of the Nova Corps but an
ex-girlfriend of Johnny Storm named
Frankie Rey who had agreed to become a
herald of Galactus to save the earth now
to find out what's going on the
Fantastic Four a journey to the blue
area of the moon to consult Watchi The
Watcher who must their surprise has no
memory of who Galactus is now when the
Fantastic Four returned earth they find
alternate universe versions of Marvel
superheroes ready to meet them in battle
and Nova who's awakened from her coma
and escaped from confinement now Nova
starts yelling about needing to destroy
the world as a Galactus would because
multiverses are mixing and reality is
folding in on itself which he says will
bring about Abraxas now in the midst of
the battle Reed Richards and an
alternate universe version of dr. druid
are taken into space by Captain universe
who explains the origin of the cosmic
abstract eternity and informed them that
the balance between chaos and order in
the multiverse has been upset before
taking them before a mysterious cosmic
entity standing in front of a pile of
dead Galactus now the entity identifies
himself as a Brock sis and sins Reid and
dr. druid back to earth in places a
warning in the sky that reads I am
coming and fiery letters and it's here
that we get our first idea of Abraxas
powers as reid explains that he is a
being with godlike powers to whom
bending reality means absolutely nothing
furthermore Reid explains that it will
take the entire combined strength of all
the heroes to battle him how he knows
this after seeing Abraxas for only a few
seconds is not something that's really
explained but I guess we'll kind of go
with it cuz you know counter books but
later on we learn from the Omni
versatile guardian Roma
that Abraxas has always existed within
the core of eternity and in contrast to
eternity who is the embodiment of
creation Abraxas is the embodiment of
destruction we also learned that to keep
Abraxas in check
eternity created a Galactus in every
universe and when one of those versions
of Galactus dies the doors of the
multiverse become unhinged giving
Abraxas his opportunity to basically
destroy everything
now as the Fantastic Four and their
allies battle Abraxas who by this time
is also acquired the ultimate nullifier
it becomes clear
they cannot defeat them on their own and
so Franklin Richards uses every bit of
his power to bring Galactus back into
existence and since the ultimate
nullifier is a part of Galactus himself
who's able to take it from Abraxas and
as a to do battle it winds up in the
hands of Reed Richards who uses it to
destroy the multiverse
so that it can be remade and
surprisingly this one encounter with the
Fantastic Four which spanned a total of
five issues is the only time we've ever
seen a brac sis in Marvel Comics
now what this means is that we have a
limited number of appearances and
therefore a limited number of feats to
draw from in determining what Abraxas
powers are but one thing we do know is
that Abraxas has managed to kill several
different versions of Galactus from
various universes as soon as we know how
powerful Galactus is the fact that
Abraxas was able to kill enough of them
to create a pile of corpses is a
testament to how powerful he is
furthermore we have this statement by
Reed Richards that reality-warping is an
effortless task for Abraxas now if
you've watched many of our beyond
omega-level videos you'll realize that
reality warping is probably the most
powerful ability that any character can
possess as it allows them to literally
imagine whatever they want into
existence and given the fact that
Abraxas is a multiversal entity this
means that he's able to manipulate
reality in more than one universe which
would place him among the strongest
reality wars in Marvel Comics now due to
how sparingly Abraxas has been used much
of his power level is implied instead of
proven by feats but being a cosmic
abstract we know that his power is
virtually limitless and that he is
nearly omnipotent and although we
haven't seen him do much we know that he
is capable of universal destruction
because the prospect of what Abraxas
would do if he wasn't stopped was so
frightening for Reed Richards but he was
willing to use the ultimate nullifier to
destroy all of reality to stop it from
coming to pass now this decision by Reed
lets us know that he did not see
any pathway to victory over Abraxas even
with Galactus having been resurrected
now with one of the most brilliant minds
in the Marvel Universe making the
determination that no combination of
heroes would be able to take down a
Brack sis so we might as well blow up
all of reality tells us that abra axis
represents a greater threat to the
Marvel multiverse than had ever been
faced up to that point and honestly guys
that's pretty much all there is to his
character I know this is going to be a
shorter video than we normally have but
it's just because there's such a limited
number of appearances to go on here and
really that makes sense if this is a guy
that requires inning the multiverse and
remaking it to basically defeat him and
so you can't really use a character this
going to require such a drastic measure
to be taken every time he shows up but
still I'm surprised that at some point
in the nearly two decades since he was
introduced no one has tried to use him
in any of the story so far nevertheless
if we're going to make a series of
videos of feature the strongest
characters in comics Abraxas has to be
included on that list without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain and make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like
now we'll catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]